that's a good argument and an orgy he
kills it yeah he either eats a ton of
[ __ ] he's just gobbling like this
just stack
go ahead what a lot of people don't know
about this sport too is that it has a
huge
it has a huge gay under following and uh
well they keep throwing dogs right right
that's what i'm saying well i'm just
saying first of all some of the youngest
men in it i've seen there's like a
there's like a group of like younger
kind of these frank wranglers or
whatever they call themselves and
uh a lot of the younger ones are gays
this is a real outlet for gays yeah he's
right on that now i'd like him to mix up
and do some big long burnt franks like
some big bratwurst like little girl
like i like my porn you know what i'm
saying i'm a small dick in my boy i
don't want i'll smile
you feel me i want small dicks here i
want small dicks in my porn and i want
the girl going like
oh
give it up like what kind of porn with
that i think that that's cool dude sad
porn yeah she's like oh look at your
[ __ ] dick what the [ __ ] like that
you're like
you pan up and he's just like yeah yeah
yeah and i go oh let's go
full circle and put on the whole team
legendary trio bringing chris and theo
what you mean you know it's the king and
the sting and the wing
[Music]
you